I would ask all Americans to keep the
men and women of Fort Hood in your
thoughts and prayers it is a tragedy for
Arizona and a tragedy for our entire
country we will take every step possible
to ensure the safety of all our people
and we're going to have to come together
and take meaningful action to prevent
more tragedies like this regardless of
the politics we will do everything in
our power to make sure whoever carried
out this cowardly act is held
responsible we're heartbroken that
something like this might have happened
again once again innocent people were
killed in part because someone who
wanted inflict harm had no trouble
getting their hands on a gun it is a
heartbreaking circumstance for these
individuals who have served our country
with great valor to be to be killed in
this fashion this is a political choice
that we make to allow this to happen
every few months in America we know that
the killers in San Bernardino used
military-style assault weapons weapons
of war to kill as many people as they
could it's another tragic reminder that
here in America it's way too easy for
dangerous people to get their hands on a
gun every time I think about those kids
it gets me mad and by the way it happens
on the streets of Chicago every day this
masker is there for a further reminder
of how easy it is for someone to get
their hands on a weapon that lets them
shoot people in a school or in a house
of worship or a movie theater or in a
nightclub